this word is copy it means coffee this
one
is kopi it means nosebleed people are
going to think that i'm ordering
nosebleed at cafes
hey guys this is inka and in this video
i will be trying to learn a new language
in only 60 days
as some of you know i am half taiwanese
and half hong kong chinese
i grew up basically speaking all three
languages
mandarin english and cantonese even as a
kid i've always been fascinated by
languages
one of the things that have always been
on my bucket list is to pick up another
language
korean for me has always been on top of
the list of languages that i wanted to
learn
i think partially because i used to be
based in east asia
and i had this goal of mastering all the
east asian languages
korea is also a country that is so rich
in culture
and history if i could get a good grasp
of this language
i'd be able to go there and actually
talk to people and get to know all of it
better
also because for right now i produce a
lot of the kpop video content here at
buzzfeed
if i'm able to understand or communicate
better in korean
it could help our talent feel more
comfortable too all of these reasons
are why i've decided to take up this
challenge of
learning a new language in 60 days for
full disclosure
i have learned korean a little bit
before but i have
forgotten pretty much most of it because
i haven't been using it at all
now my goal is that at the end of these
two months
i should at least be able to form my own
sentences
i am hoping to understand what people
are saying i am very hopeful and i am
very excited about this
i just hope i don't disappoint myself
and you guys also just to clarify i shot
all of this before the quarantine
so promise i am staying safe and i hope
you guys are staying safe too
[Music]
so to start it off i actually started to
pull out some of the old
notes i still had from my study abroad
program and i also
downloaded an app to help me with like
pronunciations
and like kind of have a refresher of
sorts
i'm actually really surprised that i
still have these notes they
remind me of just how much i've
forgotten looking
at the notes i've written before though
the way i've spelt it out up here when i
pronounce it it just
seems so similar i feel like i just need
somebody to
be here somebody to talk to to make sure
that like i'm pronouncing things right
if i get this first step wrong i feel
like i'm just gonna get everything else
wrong too so to stay on track and to
make sure that i would actually see some
improvement within these 60 days
i decided to look up where i'd be able
to learn korean in the city
and that's when i found kcc and that's
when i was introduced to un
who would become my tutor we will do
some refreshers i hope
she gets to the level where she could
conjugate
it will depend on her as much as it
depends on me
this first lesson was intense in
basically told me that i've been
pronouncing everything wrong i want to
make sure that she has the right
pronunciation
so this is our first week we definitely
have more ways to go
are you ready i'm ready i'm ready all
right
[Music]
so in and i set up a schedule where we
would meet twice a week for two hours
each time and i would be starting from
the very basics
hana
so it involved a lot of reading and
repeating after her making sure that
i was making the right sounds so let's
do that again
hannah hannah chinchon
and once i got home i would go over the
materials again i'm just going through
some of my notes
rewriting them
in
what did make it more difficult though
was that i wasn't just learning common
phrases
and words but i was learning how
sentences were structured
so that kind of tripped me up i also
started trying
to speak in korean to my korean friends
with key emphasis
on trying
[Music]
is that right yeah wow that's pretty
good um
that's what's important to you
for this week i'm actually going to be
in tokyo japan for work
which means i won't be able to go in for
my lessons and because my schedule's
kind of
crazy it also means that i don't
actually have that much time to
practice so i'm really hoping this
doesn't set me back i think being in
japan
also kind of confuses me a little bit
where
in japan because i'm learning a lot of
new phrases in order to try to get
around
i feel like sometimes i also mix up
japanese and korean phrases which is
not a good thing and i'm trying not to
do that it's hard it's really hard to
to stay on track i hope eon won't be too
disappointed in me
can you say it one more time
is
the third week definitely set me back so
i had a lot of catching up to do
a lot of revising a lot of studying and
i had to refer to
the internet to make sure my
pronunciation was okay
i also changed the language on my phone
from english to korean since i figured
that would force me to use korean
a lot more in my daily life rushing to
class now
with my sandwich because my phone's now
in korean
it takes me like three times the amount
of time i normally take
to read anything this is proving to be a
lot harder than expected
and some of my conversations within even
though it took me a while to process
what was being said
i could actually understand what she was
saying and that got me
really excited
yo
so it's pretty much the end of day right
now
i had a shoot this morning then i went
to
korean class then i had to rush back for
another shoot today during class we try
to put like sentences together
but at the same time i was also so
exhausted and
my brain literally just stopped working
and when we started we said to aim for
like 30 minutes every day but
a lot of times i have shoots or events
that go on until really late
in the evening and the biggest thing is
also because i know we're trying to
do so much within two months it is
not as easy as it sounds i'm trying to
read directions to see where i'm
supposed to go but everything in google
maps right now is in korean so i'm very
confused
and not just google maps but because all
of my notifications were now in korean
it was
kind of overwhelming and i feel like my
workflow just became
slower i was less efficient because of
how much time
it took to process everything it is now
10 pm at night right now and
i literally just got back from work and
i
am trying to do my korean homework i've
been reading the same page
for like i don't know how many times but
the information just isn't going in
i can't like my brain honestly just i
just need sleep
so i don't know i want this to work but
it's also just like
i don't know what to do
[Music]
it is week seven we're almost at the end
here
and i feel like now i'm like finally
able to understand sentences and yin and
i were having
conversations granted that she does try
to speak a little slower for me
i understand most of it
or maybe not most i get the meaning the
general meaning of what
she's trying to ask so super super
excited about that
being able to put sentences together in
korean was one of the most incredible
feelings learning about
how to say want to han
but even though i could read better now
and i could understand more things
this is when i started learning about
korean grammar
and this is the part when things got
extremely
difficult tenses olive oil
oil okay now you should be able to
say can you come to my home to eat
it tonight me like five minutes high
five high five
higher still episode okay
so i'm on my way to meet brandon and his
family
so i am hoping to use this chance to
practice a little bit of my
newly learned korean i have been tasked
to order
one person
[Music]
kimchi
foreign
okay
what is this
you're inviting me over to your
[Music]
i am on my way to my last korean class
really sad but this is it
i really hope i've come a longer way
than i think i have
i worked with inca for 60 days she
started with pronunciation
now she's generating sentences and i
think that's a
very good improvement definitely keep
studying yeah
you should be really really really proud
of yourself and for the final challenge
i tried to converse in korean with one
of my favorite k-pop stars amber
all right korean lesson thingamabob i
don't need this okay
you don't need my phone
oh
thank you
crazy thing with like mandarin and
english is that chinese also has a
really really
weird grammar yeah english too and then
you're flipping that into koreans i
empathize with your struggle and you did
amazing
thank you thank you so yeah that
concludes my 60 days of learning korean
but as you guys can probably tell this
is also really just the beginning
learning a new language really is an
ongoing process and i really don't want
to lose
any of the progress i've made so far i
also really want to know if you guys
have been trying to learn a new language
i think it would be really fun for us to
share experiences and any tips we have
in the comments below but as for now
this is my promise to myself
i am going to keep practicing i hope to
only get better from here
see you guys soon bye
[Music]
you